hi
today was a great day
every day can be a great day
uh the day to me is our sort of the
basic unit of our lives
we should strive to make every day as
good as it can be today
i didn't do a lot of korean studying but
it was still a great day
um i had played hockey this morning
which is great i love it i get out there
i work as hard as i can
no matter how i feel i didn't sleep all
that well i get there i work hard i get
in there and i shower at the end of it
nice
i feel great when i'm done
then i went to lunch at this little
bistro i had a
seafood chowder which is excellent and
then a buckwheat crepe with vegetables
and as i started beside me were three
korean ladies so i immediately chatted
them up in my limited korean which was
fun
then
on the other side of me was a fellow
with a russian girlfriend wife i didn't
explore and so i spoke to her in
russian
then
the three korean ladies left another
couple korean sat down beside me it's
unbelievable so i spoke to them they
were very interested in the fact that i
was studying korean
there were some russians off in the
corner speaking russian i didn't accost
them
but
then i went to the office we had a
meeting we reviewed all the things that
we're going to do we have some exciting
things coming up in link in terms of our
iphone and android apps
in terms of improvements that i mean i
don't want i'm not going to talk about
them but and they always take longer
than
than we expect but that was kind of
exciting then i get a phone call from my
chinese friend he says you got to come
with to dinner with us come to my place
at five we're driving out to richmond
which is an hour away
i go there oh but before that the key
thing today is that
someone on my youtube channel said why
don't you look in to talk to me in korea
and of course i know talk to me in
korean i know
soon we have some of his stuff at link
so i went to his website and there was a
lot of good stuff there which i i bought
i bought three or four items from his
website talk to me in korean just google
it talk to me in korean
and i started listening to his blog
book audio book of his blog which seems
to me very good i think the whole thing
there is going to help me in my korean
i'll be talking about it later on so
that was a major discovery talk to me in
korean
i've downloaded it i bought download it
and i'll be working out so anyway this
chinese guy phones me says you got to
come out
this this is a gentleman who lives in
china has a car dealership there but
most of the time he lives in vancouver
and so we went out
and we met with some people from
mainland china and had a phenomenal
dinner
drank some nice wine
i wasn't driving
um so it was a great day and i was
speaking lots of chinese and i was gonna
take a video but it wasn't considered
appropriate because
apparently
the government now in china has put some
restrictions on government officials
traveling
um
but no it was a good day
it was an excellent day was it
absolutely a great day so every every
day that's a good day like i i do
believe this even in terms of our
language learning we have to take credit
for the good things that happen to us or
we have to pat ourselves on the back or
or recognize
you have a good day that's a good day
um i didn't advance my korean an awful
lot but it was still a good day and
tomorrow
uh at noon
i'm going to have a chat with joo hyun
so i'm going to work hard in the morning
listening to whatever i can listen to
and try to get my korean up so that when
i speak to her
that i hope she will say gee your korean
has improved
but i may be disappointed but we will
find out tomorrow in in the meantime
that's all i have to report uh for today
on day 20 but tomorrow if i can get my
call recorder to work you'll hear me
speaking korean to joo hyun and see what
her reaction is to
the results of 20 days that i've spent
on trying to upgrade micro